foreign
Jared is with us in Coeur d'Alene Idaho
hi Jared welcome to the Ramsay show
hi guys hey I have a question regarding
cost of living
raises compared to inflation
I personally enjoy giving my customers
the cheapest service available
yet to keep up with inflation we have to
give raises
how do those two things mesh together
and is there anything we can do to
battle the inflation as a business owner
no not uh you know your job is not the
macro economy your job is to run your
business and that means take care of
your family and the families that you
pay
um that's your job the macro economy
discussion is that when things go up
when the cost
of a loaf of bread the cost of a service
the cost of a uh a pack of hot dogs
whatever it is you want to call it a
gallon of gas when when the cost of that
goes up
one of the reasons the cost of the item
has gone up to the consumer when you
raise your prices in business is because
their cost of goods has gone up if their
cost of goods are you know for instance
if I make a uh if we print a book
a a Total Money Makeover a baby steps
Millionaire's book well the cost of
paper has gone up 30 percent in the last
24 months
all right and so that's going to be
built into my pricing on the next book
that we put out agreed
if the uh if the cost of that book
includes a a dock worker to do the
shipping and a truck driver to deliver
it and both of those people get paid
more
by me to bring me that book then now the
cost of that book has gone up again the
paper cost went up and the labor cost
associated with delivering that went up
and so anytime you pay people more
inside your business you have to absorb
that in price changes and so price
increases are always not always but they
they either they have you have to do a
price increase to stay open otherwise
you're not profitable to cover your
actual cost of goods and cost of Labor
yeah
and when the cost of Labor goes up due
to cost of living raises or any other
raises uh just a shortage of uh workers
uh an example of that is um you know we
told
when America got fouchied we told all of
the service industry all the waiters and
the people that make your beds at the
hotel and uh the people in the service
world that they weren't essential
and we sent them home
told them they couldn't work
if you're a restaurant worker you're not
allowed to work and in some places we
did that for a month other places we did
it for a year
when you tell people they're not
essential and then you want them to come
back
they remember how you pissed on them
last time
and so guess what you want to hire
somebody in the service world today
pre-covered you might have done that for
ten dollars now you might be looking at
twenty five dollars
because there's a shortage of workers in
those Industries still to this day post
covet and so uh you know the economic
implications of covid are still shaking
out you create a labor disruption and a
labor price change uh and we've seen it
in other areas of Labor as well our cost
of what we pay someone to work here at
Ramsey has changed and some of the areas
pretty dramatically and some of the we
do comp studies to see where they're
charging so yeah then that means that if
I'm gonna uh
be profitable I have to raise a price
somewhere and so that person that buys
that pays more
and that's called inflation
yeah you don't and you don't have to
feel guilty about it it's just part of
no part of it but I mean what what he's
pointing out and I think it's good for
people to hear out there is when you're
walking around with a little picket in
your hand and saying I demand
15 dollars
I demand 22 dollars where I was making
10 to work at McDonald's
then the cost of McDonald's goes up to
cover your idea of you being worth more
then you don't get to about paying
more for stuff because you caused it
that's what I'm talking that's what he's
talking about and so you can't go I
don't like the fact your fast food
prices all went up and yet you're
walking around demanding that the cost
of labor at a fast food place go almost
freaking double yeah and then and then
can't fit you know of course you know
um it's it's all connected cost more you
know I mean that's why a child that's
what works because these businesses are
not evil and greedy but they also are
not not for profit that's right they
have to make a profit to stay open and
oh by the way even non-profits are
profitable
a non-profit that isn't profitable
closes out of business it's out of
business it's gone non-profit is not a
not an actual dollar amount of they
didn't make more than they spent it's
just an accounting entry and an IRS
designation
but they actually you know your church
has to take in more
than it puts out otherwise it closes
so non-profits are profitable hello and
you know and so if the cost of
electricity at your church goes up then
there you go I mean you're gonna you're
gonna if the cost of Staffing at your
church goes up because you're competing
in the marketplace for that creative
position at the church that music
director at the church you're you're
competing with the marketplace then that
you know it costs more to operate that
organization and some organizations
haven't survived that that's right so
yeah inflation includes cost of Labor
and when you've had a labor disrupt
disruption like the quarantines created
uh we haven't seen we've seen most of
the end of it but we haven't seen the
complete end of it yet
um it will calm down and smooth out
eventually but even a little three
percent five percent cost living raise
then gets built into the thing and you
can't really in business I can't stand
against that and go well I just refuse
to raise my prices well you refuse to
stay in business you know that's just
kind of dumb so so the next book you buy
from us get ready the price is going to
be more because hello you know those 10
sales we run they're not to be 12.50
they're about done I'm just saying we're
about done with a 10 sale because it's
ten dollar sales about backward it's
about upside down now and I'm about done
with it so uh that was helpful for a
while but been doing them been doing
them for 10 years and you know cost of
paper kicked kicked my butt and so I'm
gonna pass on the butt kicking all right
that's how this works that's how that's
how it works y'all I mean it's just this
is how it is so if you think it's
otherwise then you're being naive so but
it's interesting to me that we teach so
little Civics and so little economics
today that people can't make a basic
connection
I demand to be paid more but then on the
other hand I'm gonna about
inflation yeah no I don't think when you
freaking caused it
you're the essence of it I mean you know
I can't believe the cost of bread well
it cost about twice the labor to put the
bread on the Shelf now that's right that
it did so look I mean almost double it's
crazy and you can't even get the help
can't get people show up because they're
sitting at home in their mother's
basement playing Nintendo it's nuts so
we don't have that problem at Ramsey
because we're not dealing with that
level of labor we're dealing with a high
class you know generally here so we got
a whole different whole different set of
uh things that we deal with that are
wonderful by and large but yeah it's a
it's a great discussion Jared and you
know the problem was you pulled the
string on the monkey so you got you got
the Soap Box you got the soapbox
response because I can go on them for
days about this but it is interesting
how ignorant yeah you know some of this
wealthy quality stuff is and all this
stuff it's just they're ignorant of the
connection the unintended consequences
of their little shallow ideas yeah
absolutely and where they're going so
I'm glad that he pulled the string yeah
well you just every so often you have to
get out of my system